oh man my eyes are running my makeup's
running thank god i don't wear mascara
whoa
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by naomi campbell
she's a global style icon and one of the
most recognizable supermodels of all
time
you can catch her on her interview
series no filter on the naomi youtube
channel as well as the docu-series the
supermodels which is coming soon to
apple tv
naomi campbell welcome to the show thank
you so much sean thank you for having me
before we get started how into hot sauce
are you like when you go to brixton
market you just load up on the caribbean
scotch bonnet sauces
well first it was one it was jamaican
hot sauce
then it grew into a cave i went to
rwanda i got rwanda hot sauce i went to
sicily i've got sicilian hot sauce i
went to nigeria i got nigerian hustle so
now i have a bag of four horses
well i look forward to introducing you
to a bunch of new ones today are you
ready to get started i know all of them
like
fire to me
[Music]
actually i'm going to do a little shake
shawn because sometimes
with these liquidy ones they get a bit
like the liquid stays on top and you
lose the peppers
so i'm going to do a little shake and
then i'm going to pour
that's fine yes especially in transit
you know like we're doing this on uh
opposite sides of the pond over here so
uh that's good to shake it up
okay
[Music]
it's good it's mild
i'm enjoying this mild zone show so as
we mentioned up top you have an
interview series called no
filter where you and a guest ponder
life's great questions at the
intersection of culture and fashion
and i thought that your conversation
with marc jacobs was really interesting
on fashion during quarantine is it
possible to make my sweatpants
look oat couture
i think sweatpants have long been
controlled before
the the quarantine happened i mean you
had
ricardo t-shirt juventus doing it and
taking streetwear and really just
bringing it to like high fashion
i mean i just stand constantly in a
burberry or a
luchy tracksuit or a or a champion
or a valentino know whatever i feel
comfortably
what are the chances that we see a
designer hazmat
suit on the runway sometime in the next
year i think there's big chances i mean
i've been asked to put my house in that
suit into an exit into a
um a museum they asked me for the one
that i actually wore
and my burberry cake that i put on top
of it so i'm going to give it
so um very possible
[Music]
tasty
they're tasty i said i had indian food
last night
this might remind you of that
[Music]
oh god i
got mama so we can't have a naomi
campbell interview without talking about
style in the 90s a decade that really
redefined the fashion industry as a
whole
if you were to put together a timeline
of watershed moments that took
fashion out of this niche exclusionary
world and entered the era of
supermodels being celebrities and
household names what would be some of
the marquee events on that timeline
that's a very big answer that you asked
for me
and i can only tell you so much but um
it's designers like johnny versace as
you know liar
you said alone that basically put us
all together that's when we kind of saw
things turn because back in the day
the models that used to do the fashion
shows were separate from the models that
used to do the photographs and the
magazines
and i feel like my error
really came that's my the era that i
come from
kind of came in and mixed the two
together and solidified it as stay in
that way
veteran artists often have gripes with
young rappers who aren't familiar with
the catalogues of notorious big or tupac
do you feel the same way about models
who don't take the time to study design
houses or learn the history
very very smart question um
i'm not sure today how far
the what the models have time or make
the time to do the research
about the designers that they worked for
definitely in my era we did
we didn't have anyone in between the
model and designer so we had
a much more intimate and personal
relationship directly with them
not discredited in any way it's just
that now there's
more people there in between than before
i'm not saying the models today don't
get to be
close to knowing designers but i feel
like it was just
more intimate
well i just got a jamaican edge to it
this one
this one tastes to me like
you know jamaican patties yeah yeah
this one gives that taste to me there is
some uh some scotch bonnet pepper in
this one
yeah because i feel a little kickback
under my tongue
that's when you know it's rising
according to ceo marco bizarri more than
half of gucci's sales last year were to
people
under the age of 35. do you have any
insight as to why
gucci seems to garner such strong favor
particularly amongst young people
i mean alexander i feel he loves to go
into like
the vintage and but do it in his own way
so this generation they missed all that
i've seen it
for them it's new you know what it means
i get that they would be fascinated and
love it where do you stand on celine
casting tick-tock stars as show models
is that a crime against fashion or is
that genius
i wasn't aware of it i've just been
enlightened now
i don't see anything wrong with it
people choose to be creative
in their own in different ways so that's
the way
pettiness the man who wants to do his
show when using tik tok stars then from
there
as someone who understands fashion's
aberrations and eccentricity
how would you explain people wearing
off-white with the zip tie tag
still on the clothes how would you
explain that to like my dad
i don't know how to explain it to your
dad but
i have to tell you i had to at when i
came when i first got my off-white i
love mr virgil avlo
thank you so much i wasn't sure do i
keep it on or do i take it off
because my generation i would take it
off my friend's son linda's son
evangelista said no no you're supposed
to keep it on
so i'm like okay even on my sneakers yes
you're supposed to keep it on
so that's how i became educated about
keeping on the tag
was through my friend lindy's son
moki i'm not into smokey too much but
let's give it a go
i like barbecue i like the barbecue
sauce this has kind of that barbecue
smokey vibe to it i'd say this was my
least favorite so far let me have one
more place
these favorites so far not into the
smoke
so brixton where you grew up like harlem
in new york or shibuya and tokyo it's
one of these neighborhoods that you see
emblazoned on fast fashion
t-shirts to connote a certain level of
stylishness
what does brixton really stand for and
what do you think the fashion shorthand
of brixton is even supposed to mean
can i just say one name and that's sure
to sum it up
david bowie
[Music]
that's it it's music and it's fashion
says it all in one can't get any better
than that can you
what do you see is the biggest
difference in the style sensibilities of
americans versus brits
oh no darling we're cutting edge we've
always been cutting edge
sorry to tell you we get it first you
get it later
is from where uh we actually make this
one believe it or not
this is yours yeah we make this product
but you know what
naomi if you don't like it tell me the
truth i know you always speak the truth
i'll tell you the truth i'm i'm a
straight up gemini i'm not gonna lie
hey i know that okay
[Music]
okay
keeping in suspense i'm on the edge of
my suit
this is nice you can definitely mix this
in a pasta sauce
no yeah that's the move that's the move
okay so i give it thumbs up
wow humbled humbled all right naomi
campbell we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that gram where
we do a deep dive on our guest instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
context
so i'll show you the picture you just
tell us the bigger story
here you are pictured with sasha baron
cohen as ali g
do you find his bruno character to be an
accurate depiction
of the fashion industry's megalomaniacs
oh sasha i love him um it's an
exaggeration
it's a caricature of the designers but
it's not how they actually are enough
but it's a fun caricature
i did ali g i was so nervous
and sasha was so like sweet and trying
to make me feel comfortable
but then you know i'm always nervous
before i do anything
including this and then i'll get there
and then i'll somehow overcome my fear
next thing i've got the whip and i'm
like being dominant dominating being
predominate tricks
and you were a lot of fun i'm very happy
i did it it's just so funny because it's
just come up a lot in the last few days
here we have the famous spill at the
vivian westwood show maybe the most
famous runway spill of all time have you
been able to run back the tape and
figure out exactly what went wrong in
that moment
i don't have to run back the tape to
watch it i can run back the tape in my
head
because first you think i just have
white tights on
but they're not just white tights
they're rubber
so i couldn't feel my feet
my toes so but also there's a there's a
way to walk in
vivian's westwards shoes you have to
walk
on your tiptoes not on the heels so you
everything on the front not on the back
i just went walking like as if i was
walking in a normal shoe
no no no that's why i fell
might be might be this might be the one
so during a recent interview with mark
jacobs you guys discussed his
infamous grunge rock show for perry
ellis in 1992.
what do you remember about the reaction
to that show specifically and looking
back
what did critics get wrong well they
were blown away i didn't know they
didn't expect that
i loved mark's conviction behind it
because it's just what he wanted to do
and it's what he loved
and by the end of that show the whole
room loved it too the whole fashion
edition of two
and then it was everyone trying to shoot
it yeah and i think it too kind of shows
the intrinsic link
between fashion and music you know
because here comes this thing that's
like a total disruption and total
reversal in large part because of this
music
trend that was going on in the pacific
northwest with bands like nirvana
it was great it was so perfect the
timing of that
and i mean there we were and the
glamorous dresses the beautiful
dresses the finale dresses and then it
just went
upside down and that was you know
and that's what it's about that's what
makes it fun that's why i love what i do
still after all these years because you
never know what's gonna happen
[Music]
this one looks scary i'm trying to look
at your face
i taste the vinegar i write about the
vinegar
it's okay but this one i know is gonna
start burning me in five minutes
this one is purely meant to make you
feel fire
so one of the things that's always
fascinated me about the world of fashion
from the outside looking in is the
complicated and savage politics of
sitting
front row why is sitting in the front
row why is it such an
object of obsession so important when
you're in the front row seat
you get to see everything from head to
toe you're going to miss
a little bit as you go up higher you're
in the show
basically you're in it um
you know the camera is gonna get you for
me fashion shows have changed because
now with the
with the phone everyone's videoing so
they don't clap as much as they used to
back in the day when i was in our heyday
of doing shows it was so much fun the
ambiance was amazing because then people
were clapping and
we could really feel the audience i mean
it's all going to work out in the end
you know what i mean there are worse
things to be worried about than a front
row seat and fighting over a front row
seat i should say
[Music]
it's a big step up huh thank you for the
warning sean
oh wow oh yeah yeah
there's not even any and there's any hot
sauce in it it's just pepper
there's fire oh my god yep
i'm gonna go in for a sip too carefully
i don't got that one at all
i'm sorry
i'm gonna have to put my tongue in milk
there you go
it's like a russian bath house
lucky how
so i've read that some of your favorite
places to visit include brazil
egypt italy japan cambodia burma
food wise where's your favorite place
for a street food snack
i can't speak
[Music]
my eyes are watering i love brazilian
food
indian food italian food
[Applause]
what i i love in brazilian food i love
by bayan food from the south of brazil
african food senegalese
czecho-gen yasser
nigerian food um
ferrero it's like a spinach with fish
i mean i love i love food food is very
important to me
i can tell all right two more to go
here naomi campbell how you doing uh
i don't know sean my nose is running
that's a
sign my eyes are watering that's a sign
and my tongue is on fire
and i'm heating up from inside oh
i hope i don't faint on you has anyone
ever fainted on this show
i've seen a lot of things go down but
i've yet to see a faint naomi you could
be the first
and i'd feel helpless over here on the
other side of the zoom you know
okay
[Music]
wow that's numbing i feel like it's just
like
a deep profound pepper taste you know oh
my lord of mercy
give me strength here so as someone with
a front row seat to the changes in
fashion over the last 30 years you have
a unique view on the cyclical nature of
culture
what's one fashion trend that will never
go away and then one that you hope never
comes back
the black dress is never going out of
style
and i'm not i'm into
whoa i'm not into crocs sorry crocs
nothing against your brand it's just not
my i find it a lazy shoe
you've done a staggering thousand plus
magazine covers in your life
pound for pound which one is your
favorite
it's hard to pick a favor um
of course i hope the ones that are there
that were
first first to be the black english girl
in my country of british vogue first to
be the first black woman on the cover of
frenchburg
for me the ones that broke barriers for
my culture
first to be on the cover of time
magazine all of those
ones are ones that i hold dear but i
don't hold dear for me a whole deal for
the culture
and the rest is my life
we're almost there naomi we're almost my
eyes are running my makeup's running
thank god i don't wear mascara
whoa but we made it but we made it naomi
almost my i'm gonna blow my nose so much
all right so this one is called apollo
i'm scared i'm scared sean
i get it i understand i understand but
i'm right here with you
i'm right here with you all right i'm
glad for it all right cheers naomi what
a ride it's been very fun
[Music]
okay naomi campbell here we are at the
curtain call of our dinner date with the
wings of death
we've fully dissected your fashion point
of view and challenged your unshakeable
spice tolerance but to close things out
i want to do an eyeball test i've always
marveled at the creativity and nerve of
hot sauce makers that on the bottle can
have
everything from a friendly mascot turtle
to a hellish landscape of fire and
brimstone
so to close things out i would be
honored if you could maybe
pick out a couple bottles tell me your
favorites tell me your least favorites
but i want you to forget about taste
this is all about the aesthetic and
artistic
appeal of the label
the bomb is the worst because the bomb
looks like a cd cover for music for
other music
it's like a music cover to me
hell on fire not into it either didn't
no
no no creativity there
angry goat is cute i like angry girl
and but the classic for me is
the west indian because that's the
classic to me because that's what they
looked like to me
when i was growing up those are what the
classic
hot sauce bottles looked like with the
face of a person
you know back in the day well if i know
shaquanda
they're gonna be very excited about that
and look at you
naomi campbell conquering the hot ones
gauntlet
oh my goodness oh my god i was so scared
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you naomi
campbell
this camera possibly a camera be if you
set one up
but probably just the one that you're
looking at let the people know what you
have going on in your life
i've been really i love your show and i
remember saying
i want to try that because of my love of
rock source
so um this was a big fear and challenge
i've made it through and now as you know
we announced
we are working on the supermodels of
docuseries with apple
and many many things are coming i love
the surprises the element of surprises
still
still does it for me
good job naomi good job
thank you
lucky how
what is up spice lords greek god apollo
here to tell you
that i've harnessed the power of the sun
you thought zeus's lightning bolts were
bad
get yourself a load of this it's the
last dab apollo
the hottest last dab we've ever made you
can get yourself a bottle of your very
own last dab apollo
on october 22nd at heatonis.com
don't miss your shot to get a bottle of
your own
you